en 1942 sous la france occupée la jeune
versaillaise jacqueline fleury alors âgé
de 20 ans entre en résistance avec sa
famille à le distribuer tracts journaux
clandestins participent à des réseaux de
renseignement et prend chaque jour de
plus en plus de risques quand je
rentrais de paris avec mon petit
chargement de journaux clandestins
on pouvait être arrêté dans le métro
dans les rues dans les gares dont les
gars surtout il y avait la police
française la police allemande pour nous
la gestapo
arrêté jacqueline fleury letang février
1944 dans son appartement versailles et
elle est alors envoyé avec sa famille à
la prison de fresnes puis déporté en
allemagne s'ensuivent sept jours de
transfert confiné dans un wagon
direction le camp de concentration de
ravensbrück
nous recevions un numéro puisque à
partir de cet instant nous n'étions plus
des êtres humains nous étions d'échec
c'est à dire des morceaux là c'est la
négation de l'humain l'an c'est la
négation de l'être
en l'espace d'un an jacqueline changera
trois fois de camp elle travaillera pour
l'armurerie allemande en tant que
prisonnière en 1945 elle s'évade avec sa
mère et deux autres détenus elles seront
rapatriés en france par l'armée rouge
comme on avait toujours vécu par terre
je trouvais les bords des trottoirs
extraordinaire ça m'attirait pour
m'asseoir et j'entends j'entendrai
toujours ma mère me dire mais tu ne peux
pas faire sans nous sommes à versailles
un témoignage douloureux que cette
résistance était attaché a rapporté
pendant plus de 70 ans dans les collèges
et lycées un devoir de mémoire pour
transmettre son héritage culturel aux
nouvelles générations
au fond quand on a pénétré dans un camp
c'est aussi quelque chose que je dis aux
enfants que je rencontre le professeur
évidemment on ne sort jamais
complètement d'un camp il n'y a pas un
jour où on ne retrouve pas quelque chose
comptait les jours depuis sept depuis ce
depuis 45 ou bien ça fait jour
sans compter tout ce qu'on va laisser
toutes nos compagnes tous styles
et tous tous que oui on a encore
aucun dentaire